方面ガチャでプレイシューティングする
するとおっ
もう大丈夫だ商品の仕事なので
ハートの気持ち
と考えられますね
ポジと考え端から少し入っ
分かりません
すると思ったんです
あとず通知が寄せられた
uh
みなさんこんにちは
和美社長の畑
そうしないに
安積冊をです
[音楽]
失礼致しました
決して毎年やるわけではありませんが
今年もやってまいりました
始め撮影の畑
新メンバーオーディションを開催いたします
始め車道の畑
今では
チャンネル登録させるが140万人を超え
[音楽]
約1年でここまでやってまいりました
ん
[音楽]
このオーディションでは
普段
風目社長の畑には
沢山の
小汚い出演者がいますが
オーディションに
受かった方には
始めシャツを畑の出演のみではなく
動画のメタの考案
動画編集などを含む
ゾウ2的なはず3冊をの畑の運営に
携わって頂きたいと考えております
[音楽]
現時点での
増中メンバー
該当するゾウ2メンバーといたしましては
第1
良平先生
[音楽]
トマトくん
そして私肇社長
[音楽]
田澤龍星丸
該当しております
このオーディションに受かった方には
私肇社長
そして
始め者増の畑とともに
動画制作
ok か
いう業
アドラー
boast などの
さまざまな分野でともに
どうするよしっ
ともに活動していければいいなと思っております
オーディションのを好きかんですか
2019年3月16日の土曜日から
2019年3月の泉日の金曜日
23:59までとさせていただきます
何が来ましたその他の詳しいオーディションの内容につきましては
動画の概要欄の url にございますのでぜひそちらのご確認をよろしくお願い致し
ます
それでは
肇社長の畑新メンバーオーディション
たくさんのご応募をお待ちしております
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ